all right gloomy so sometimes sites ask
for like a phone number for security
purposes and I'm always actually afraid
to get my my phone number one I just
don't want random people calling me all
the time but how do you think about that
when is it valuable or maybe not so
valuable yeah it's actually super
important that when a site asks you for
a security phone number that you
provided
um I think most people would agree that
they wouldn't hesitate to give their
credit card company their phone number
because in the case of fraud you do want
them to contact you and to verify those
charges so that you know you're not
responsible for them Etc in the same way
providing your phone number to these
online companies gives a way for the
companies to contact you in case that
there's issues in addition to that the
phone number itself is actually a
security mechanism so for example a lot
of us on banking services we try to log
in and then the banking service would
send us an SMS code
um sent to your mobile phone number and
then you're able to enter that before
you're even able to log in and and what
that does is it actually prevents that
fraud from even happening and so instead
of just the bank calls you because
there's fraud it's like hey let's
prevent the fraud in the first place I I
have to say that last point is very
important like people think this is all
theoretical I on a not every day that
would really freak me out but you know
several times in the past year I get a
little code like you know it's almost
trying to log into your account and
there's a Code I'm like oh no so somehow
maybe someone broke in or they're
creating a new I don't know what's going
on but the fact that I take comfort that
they didn't get the code that I got the
code and they wouldn't be able to log in
and that kind of goes into you know is
that what we're talking about when we're
talking about two-factor authentication
that you have to have you know kind of a
two devices that you know uh uh say a
hacker in a in a foreign country or a
bad actor might not have access to
yes absolutely you're right that because
that code was only sent to your phone
number it was not sent to that attacker
and so they cannot get in they're
stopped at that point
um and also if people don't like phone
numbers there's lots of different ways
that you can do two-factor
authentication
um we can send uh prompts to your device
there's these things called security
Keys some people might have heard of
there's a big variety